me on this historic day from outside the
white house
and it's great to see you you know
kaylee
at the beginning of this we we were
watching some things that we never
thought we'd
we'd see and it's been a tough road
but it seems like and this is not a cure
but it seems like we are coming now in
this battle with a new weapon
oh there's no doubt about it having not
one but two vaccines
that have ninety-five percent efficacy
and as monsters always been emphasizing
we have a portfolio of six vaccine
two others in phase three clinical trial
that could come on the back end
of these two this is remarkable progress
it's a medical miracle as president
trump tweeted today
this should have been five years down
the road potentially but we got it done
now by tearing down red tape it's a
great day for america
this is an achievement we can all
celebrate together
now you mentioned president trump in a
tweet and i want to show everybody this
the president
has decided to delay a plan to
fast-track vaccines for white house
staff members
tweeted this people working in the white
house should receive the vaccine
somewhat later in the program
unless specifically necessary i have
asked that this be
the adjustment that this adjustment be
made i am not scheduled to take the
vaccine
but look forward to doing so at the
appropriate time
kaylee this was actually you know kind
of a reversal of the presidential policy
directive
40 which says that for continuity of
government the white
house staff and others should go first
why did the president decide this
yeah that policy directive was actually
passed by president obama
we were putting that into place but what
the president decided is
look frontline workers need to come
first our
our residents and long-term care
facilities need to come first we will
still have continuity of government
key officials like situation room staff
among others
i will have access to this vaccine um
some certain members of congress so
there will be continuity of government
but he is unashamed and saying look
number one it's the most vulnerable it's
our heroic frontline workers who should
be time person of the year by the way
uh and it should be our residents in
long-term care facilities
one more about cobit 19 and then we'll
move on
i was reading through what we could uh
with the relief bill that's coming up
you know there's six billion dollars set
aside to help with the vaccination
distribution
my goodness congress come on is the
president going to have to go over to
capitol hill to get this thing moving
look we want to see this get done and
you know i talked with the chief of
staff about this this morning and
you know he said nancy pelosi
unfortunately is putting the interest of
trial lawyers
first here because look these trial
lawyers
are the ones who are going to go after
small businesses who
that's the last thing they need is as
they're trying to whether through covet
is all of this litigation and liability
on their hands and she's prioritizing
the interests of trial lawyers
unfortunately over that of the american
people and we also want the money to go
directly to the american people and
forms
of direct payment checks not siphoned
through state and local governments
where it never really sees the light of
day so that's our priority but come on
nancy pelosi
come get serious and negotiate with us
that's what we're asking for
yeah and and you know we can look at
this in a bipartisan manner too it takes
two sides of the bicameral chamber to
talk about these things maybe they can
use their powers of persuasion
uh to get us going forth because the
vaccine is rolling and they're going to
need that money to distribute it
okay president trump took aim at
attorney general william barr
saying he should have stepped up and set
the record straight
after joe biden said his son did not
make any money from china during the
presidential debate
here's the president all he had to do is
say an investigation is going on
when you affect an election bill barr
frankly
did the wrong thing when they are saying
things making statements and the press
is purposely not reporting it bill barr
i believe
not believe i know had an obligation to
set the record straight
just like robert mueller set the record
straight
what's your reaction to that if
president trump's exactly right and his
analogy could not be more appropriate to
robert mueller who
in a rare move came out and said that
this buzzfeed story is just not true
when you have one of the nation's
largest newspapers
banned from twitter uh when you have
entities like the new york times calling
the hunter biden
information russia misinformation
ironically the same publication that won
pulitzer's on
russia disinformation and when they're
out there saying this and it's being
echoed across
every single airwave except fox i would
point out
you have an obligation to come out
because you are affecting an election
by not coming out and saying that this
investigation exists and it is not in
fact
russia misinformation is there a divide
between the president to the united
states and attorney general bill barr
over this issue because he didn't come
out and say what was going on before the
election
yeah you know there's a clear
frustration i'll leave it at that but um
he's frustrated he's very public about
it and you know the country was misled
unfortunately by a number of news
outlets saying that this was a fact-free
conspiracy theory i was right there with
the president
when he was interviewing with 60 minutes
leslie stahl where she wouldn't even let
him speak on the hunter biden scandal
said we won't we don't air things like
this on 60 minutes
uh well it was truthful all along the
facts were there
it was ignored and it's unfortunate uh
that that the attorney general didn't
come out
all right we'll follow the news as it
comes i know the president wants
somebody special
put on this he said prosecutor maybe
special counsel going forward
so that the case might be looked at into
the potential
future of the next administration let's
move to this
senate homeland security committee
chairman ron johnson said
this about his investigation into hunter
biden
we've only got a response from from
hunter and devin's attorney
not to cooperate nobody else has even
responded to us
that contrasts i think sharply with the
for example president trump's children
and his associates that voluntarily
submitted to literally hundreds of
hours of transcribed interviews that
turned over thousands of documents
didn't require subpoena in most cases
why are they you know basically hiding
in the weeds
hiding in the weeds kaylee yeah that's
exactly right and what a contrast you
know i had colleagues like my friend
hope hicks who was hauled before
congress
um don jr others over nothing over a
fake
investigation uh into russia collusion
ties that never existed and then here
uh they're being stonewalled because
there are real questions here we were
told it was all fake it's not the case
but they should do exactly what the
trump children members of the trump
administration has have done which is to
be transparent
there's nothing to see there's also no
reason to hide
all right i do want to get to georgia
here the new warnings that the hunter
biden probe is on the line as early
voting begins
today in that pivotal georgia senate
runoff
those two races that will decide the
power in the u.s senate
here's a former white house
communications director alyssa farah
what's going to matter frankly is who is
in control of the senate
i think we've seen that if it's just
democrats we're not going to get answers
to these basic
questions around hunter biden's business
finances so we've absolutely got to make
sure that republicans keep control of
the senate
so we get answers on these
now that's an interesting take i mean if
if republicans don't retain
a majority of the senate does this thing
go away
yeah yeah the investigation uh would
seem to go away because they would be in
control of all levers of the government
so you know we'll see what happens on
january 5th um but it's truly
investigations depend on having
investigatory power
all right before i let you go just a
quick wrap-around question because the
big story of today
are the vaccinations um you know as you
look ahead
and operation warp speed what should
america see next you said that you have
those
six we'll see another come online on
thursday
next steps yes that's exactly right and
this delivery i don't want to
underestimate
just how important this delivery was and
how nuanced it was 145 sites today
425 sites tomorrow another 66 on
wednesday there were literally
trial runs uh delivery dry runs just to
make sure that we had it just perfect so
that every possible life was saved this
delivery is
tremendous uh and then these new new
vaccines in phase three clinical trial
astrazeneca and johnson
johnson showing hope as well so many
vaccines to come a great testament to
president trump
kailey mcinerney good to see you thank
you